at least 22 people have been arrested in
Sri Lanka during the latest
anti-government protests led by
University students by condemning the
international monetary fund bailout deal
and the austerity measures imposed since
as Manel Fernandez reports from Colombo
the students are demanding an end to
what they call the government's
repression
students have taken to the streets of a
break
citing a number of concerns they have
talked about the international monetary
fund agreement with the government which
the government says was so vital to
securing a three billion dollar bailout
package to lift the economy of the
doldrums now here outside the open
University is where the students have
sort of regrouped and ended after
playing sort of cat and mouse with
police with Riot squads with a special
task force all day essentially the
government generally cracks down on
protests the students don't have much
kind of flexibility to take to the
streets the government has said that
there mustn't be disruption of people on
the roads traffic movement and things
like that but according to the students
they are being repressed their voices
are not being allowed to be heard now
the students say that the government
essentially what they call the runnel
Roger Parks the Junta is dictating the
dictates of the IMF and essentially
actually
undermining free education free health
care essentially social welfare programs
and
undermining all of these things in a way
that is really detrimental to the Sri
Lankan people they say they will raise
their voices they also have concerns
about what's happening to the university
education system that the government is
planning to bring in private education
and things like that so today's protest
that you saw there was like a decoy
protest there was another protest in a
different location with the government
deploying massive amounts of police of
military
to bring it under control and keep it
contained Fernandez Al Jazeera Colombo